mardi soir à berlin l'image d'une europe
soudée face à la crise aux côtés du
président polonais le chancelier
allemand et emmanuel macron appelé à
l'apaisement des tensions autour de
l'ukraine la paix et la stabilité du
continent européen sont notre trésor et
nous considérons que notre devoir est de
tout faire pour le préserver la deuxième
chose c'est consolider et défendre à
chaque instant l'unité des européens et
des alliés
européens
territoriales
pour le président français ce
déplacement à berlin conclu deux jours
de négociations intenses pour éviter un
conflit meurtrier le matin même à kiev
il négocier avec son homologue ukrainien
objectif apaiser les tensions via
l'application des accords de minsk eux
signent en 2015 censée mettre fin au
conflit dans le donbass à l'est de
l'ukraine
mais avant cela le dirigeant ukrainien
volodimir zelensky attend un signe du
président russe
en clair kiev attend de voir si moscou
va retirer les quelques cent mille
soldats russes déployées à la frontière
ukrainienne lors de sa rencontre avec
emmanuel macron lundi vladimir poutine
était resté mutique sur la question